Russia's Relentless shelling of Ukraine
did not let up even as the regime faced
an unprecedented threat from inside its
own borders at least three ukrainians
were killed in Russian airstrikes on key
the shelling came as Wagner forces
marched towards Moscow this thing is a
disaster for Putin for the military and
it's a gift from Heaven to the
ukrainians a former Canadian ambassador
to Russia believes the armed Rebellion
is another sign the Kremlin is losing
the war
on the same day as the advance the
Ukrainian military announced its
regaining territory near bakmut the
Wagner group captured the town last
month this is going to deplete Russian
motivation which is pretty lousy to
start with the Ukrainian Canadian
Congress believes the upheaval may
present an opportunity on the
battlefield our best hope our best
scenario is that it will allow the
Ukrainian Army to advance back to
reclaim territory and positions that it
will demoralize the Russian forces uh
and and lose their supply lines in terms
of equipment and ability to keep
shelling and firing NATO leaders remain
cautious U.S Secretary of State Anthony
blinken called his G7 counterparts
including foreign affairs minister
Melanie Jolie while prime minister
Justin Trudeau held an emergency meeting
with some of his cabinet ministers I
have been briefed on the events
unfolding in Russia Trudeau tweeted
we're in contact with our allies and we
will continue to monitor the situation
closely the Western world needs to
intensify the uh the amount of weapons
the ammunition that it's sending to
Ukraine so that it can fully take
advantage of this situation prime
minister Justin Trudeau is headed to
Iceland for a summit of Nordic Nations
the leaders are expected to discuss
Russian aggression in Ukraine and now
the Russian turmoil from within